hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
this video is an extract from my book
new thinking the story about the people
who built the world around us
today we all know Pixar's the king of
animated film but what many people may
not realize is that while they were
trying to make the original Toy Story
they almost went bankrupt let's see how
it happened few TV
[Music]
Pixar began in 1979 as the graphics
group subsidiary of the Lucasfilm
computer division this graphics group
was headed by Edwin Catmull of the New
York Institute of Technology the
graphics group wanted to make a computer
animated feature film from 1979 they
attempted to produce such a film for an
early 1980s release the project was
titled the works and it was to be 90
minutes long but it would never be the
computers of the time were too slow and
underpowered to create a feature-length
film during the process one of the team
members calculated the amount of time it
would take to render the frames needed
for the film it would take seven years
despite more powerful hardware becoming
available the film was eventually
abandoned in 1986 the works would have
been the first entirely 3d
computer-generated film had it been
finished as intended by the time it was
abandoned
just over 1/10 of the film had been
completed
in the same year in 1986 the Lucasfilm
graphics group would spin out of
Lucasfilm as picks up a standalone
corporation with Edward and cap Miller's
president to fix the problem of the slow
computers the Pixar team decided to work
on their own computer hardware the
result was the image Pixar computer at a
price of $220,000 this is image
computing the Pixar family of image
computers consists of the original Pixar
image computer the new lower priced
Pixar tool and includes a C compiler and
software toolkits for developing
specific applications Pixar's image
computers are being used in medical
imaging remote sensing graphic arts
including 3d design and animation and
scientific visualization it was powerful
for the time around 50 times faster than
conventional equipment a theme that
would traditionally take around 15
minutes to render was shortened to about
18 seconds each frame was computed in
eight to ten minutes on the Pixar image
computer roughly 50 times faster than
many computer renderings be as exciting
as all of this was the fledgling Pixar
needed investment money Steve Jobs CEO
of next computers had just left Apple
and he liked the idea of combining art
and technology he would invest 10
million dollars into the new company
from this transaction Jobs became a
majority shareholder acquiring 70%
ownership despite the change in
ownership dynamics Pixar's ultimate goal
was still the same to create a fully
computer-generated animated film Walt
Disney Studios subsequently bought a few
Pixar image computers and custom
software written by Pixar Disney wanted
the technology to be part of their
computer animation production system or
caps with caps the painstaking and
inking of 2d animation was now computer
assisted saving effort and money the
first film to use caps would be the
rescuers down under in 1990
was the first feature film to be 100%
assisted by computers Aladdin in 1992
and the Lion King in 1994 would both use
the cap system it would be used up until
Pocahontas in 1995 with the limited
clientele of Disney for Cap's
the computer sales were lackluster for
Pixar realizing that financial trouble
was coming jobs suggested to release the
Pixar image computer to markets which
would be interested engineers geologists
and the medical field to get this
underway
Pixar employee John Lasseter went to
work creating short completely cgi
demonstrations to show off the Pixar
image computer technology the demos
included jr. the Pixar lamp in 1986 and
tin toy in 1988 Lasseter who had been
obsessed with toys from childhood had a
knack for injecting inanimate objects
with personality and character without
ever having them talk this was the
critical essence for early Pixar films
it took us a long time to build the
technical foundation to do this stuff we
were pioneering every step of the way we
Pixar invented all this stuff but as
John says we don't view ourselves as a
technology company or our product is
content we're an entertainment company
and all this technology really is just
in the service of the storytelling right
the service of the creative people and
and computer animation is even a little
bit of a misnomer the computers don't do
the animation they do the drawing and
they crank on these drawings for like
you know three hours buy one of the
fastest computers in the world which is
why that the drawings are
three-dimensional
but the animators act you know I've
watched John and his team work and they
they're the heart and soul of the
characters they do all the acting not
the computers the short CGI animated
films cause Disney to realize the full
potential in this kind of filmmaking in
an ironic twist John Lasseter had
originally been fired from Disney for
pitching of a fully CGI film this was
after he was shown Tron by two work
colleagues after seeing jr. the Pixar
lamp and the other short CGI films
Disney now wanted John Lasseter back
defiant John chose stay at picks up he
would tell Edwin Catmull quit I can go
to Disney and be a director or I can
stay here and make history
unquote despite groundbreaking
demonstration films the Pixar image
computer never sold well in fact only
three hundred computers were ever sold
Pixar tried making CGI TV commercials
and selling software for Windows and
Macintosh but it wasn't enough the
inadequate sales threatened to put Pixar
itself out of business and financial
losses grew
jobs poured more and more money into the
project in exchange for an increased
stake in the company his total
investment was approaching 50 million
dollars this gave him control of the
entire company but almost drove him into
personal bankruptcy Pixar was still
struggling and eventually had to sell
off their computer hardware business and
lay off staff it looked like it was
going to be the end for Pixar as they
had an unexpected Savior luckily by 1991
Moore's law meant that animation great
computers were finally just powerful
enough to create and render a complete
animated feature film and
just a small demonstration Disney we now
realize that they couldn't get Pixar
employee John Lasseter back decided to
strike a deal with Pixar instead it was
a historic 26 million dollar deal to
produce three computer animated feature
films the first of which was Toy Story
without this contract Pixar probably
would have closed the stores a few years
later Pixar got to work on Toy Story
with John Lasseter as the director and
Steve Jobs as the executive producer
the first 30-second test would be
delivered to Disney in 1992 and the
initial preview impressed Disney oh did
not remain well though the collaboration
between the two companies became tense
as Disney executives continuously
scrapped script ideas brought forward by
Pixar for example Disney cast woody as
an edgy tyrannical jerk as Tim Allen
would remark while recording the voice
of the character at the halfway point of
production in 1993 with heads and ideas
clashing a preview screening of Toy
Story was shown to the upper management
of Disney it was a disaster
upper management absolutely hated it and
indeed so did John Lasseter as lessiter
put it the movie was a story filled with
the most unhappy main characters I've
ever seen the movie production was shut
down immediately
and it seemed like the dream of a cgi
feature film would never come to pass
but Lasseter didn't give up he told
Disney that he would revise the script
in just two weeks he somehow delivered
and the result was good enough for
production to resume in 1994 for context
it's important to note that the
production of such a film using early
90s technology was no easy task each
frame took between 45 minutes to 30
hours to render this depended on the
complexity and detail within the scenes
every eight seconds of film in which a
character was speaking took the
animators a week to complete every shot
would pass through eight teams and 300
computer processes running 24 hours a
day but disaster was still looming
despite receiving funding Pixar
continued to lose money the Pixar image
computer had been a failure and there
wasn't enough income coming from
software and CGI TV commercials to
offset the cost of the Toy Story project
Steve Jobs as chairman of the board and
now as Felina was getting nervous and
who wouldn't be after spending 50
million dollars of their own money on a
seemingly failing project even as late
as 1994 Jobs contemplated selling Pixar
to Hallmark cards and also Microsoft
co-founder Paul Allen
luckily the sentiment would change as
the film neared completion as the
beautiful computer-generated world of
Toy Story began to take shape jobs
marveled at what he saw and realized
that Pixar would be historic after all
Toy Story represents the computer
graphics community contributing not just
special effects to a motion picture but
the entire motion picture itself it's a
breakthrough on the scale of Technicolor
Snow White and Star Wars and I think
that that is an achievement that many
people in this room I should take proud
ownership in Toy Story went on to grace
more than three hundred and seventy
three million dollars worldwide when
Pixar held its initial public offering
on November 29th 1995 it exceeded
Netscape as the biggest IPO of 1995 and
I'm sure when you saw Toy Story for the
first time you were just as blown away
as I was the film looked more realistic
than any computer-generated imagery I
had seen before every leaf every small
detail was spot-on it captured my
imagination and the imagination of a
whole industry
Toy Story inspired videogames theme park
attractions merchandise and three
sequels Toy Story made toys cool again
for the 90s and there was no doubt that
Toy Story single-handedly saved Pixar
and the rest was history
Pixar went on to produce hits like a
bug's life the Monsters Inc series the
Finding Nemo series the incredible
series wall-e cars and the list goes on
in 2006 they would be purchased by
Disney for seven point four billion
dollars at the time it made Steve Jobs
the largest shareholder in Disney Pixar
is now beloved brand in the film
industry and their latest film Toy Story
4 is still melting hearts but after
seeing all of this is strange to think
that they were so very close to failing
I wonder how the computer animation
industry would look today if Pixar went
out of business all of those years ago
if you want to know about more amazing
stories and the history of humanity in
the context of Science and Technology
and you want to learn about those people
and teams who built the world around us
and invented the things we use each and
every day and just how all of this links
together definitely check out my book
new thinking but being so honored to
have people reach out to me and just
tell me how much they've learned and how
much it's impacted their way of looking
at the world so that wraps it up for
this video thanks for watching if you
want to see stuff like this and much
more feel free to subscribe to this
channel also feel free to check out the
cold fusion podcast anyway this has been
- gogo and you've been watching cold
fusion and I'll catch you again soon for
the next video cheers guys
[Music]
are you thinking